was für eine Nachricht ein kollaboalbum
von Bushido und Sido ich glaube damit
hätte jetzt keiner gerechnet wobei da
habe ich exklusive Infos man hätte es
Anfang des Jahres ahnen können aber
angefangen am Anfang der Geschichte
2010 Ende gab es ja eine Rap
Jahresbilanz von Sido wo er Bushido gute
Besserung gewünscht hat und damit fing
dann das ganze vertragen an Bushido
hatte ja einen wandscheibenvorfall und
über Twitter haben die beiden sich dann
vertragen und jetzt hier auf bild.de zum
ersten Mal dann auch ein Fotodokument wo
die beiden sich die Hand reichen aber
ein kollaboalbum ja damit hätte
vielleicht keiner gerechnet Anfang des
Jahres gab es diese Bravo HipHop und m
darin eine Geschichte
welche Rapper sich wie vertragen oder
nicht vertragen oder streiten und das
fanden wohl einige ziemlich blöd weil
die Geschichte eher Streit schürend war
oder so empfunden wurde und bushido hat
am Tag des Erscheinens diesen Tweet
getwittert wie kliegstum da jetzt in die
schusslin geraten ist weiß ich nicht
genau
aber das spannende daran ist er kündigt
dieses kollaboalbum an ganz klar jetzt
im Nachhinein sieht man es damals konnte
man es glaube ich nicht ahnen zu
unwahrscheinlich war es ja aber jetzt
ist es raus ich bin gespannt auf die
ersten Tracks und kann nur sagen stay
tuned